à voir
et venir passer une journée ici pour
voir le travail qui est fait par la
police dans le mouvement emmaüs dans
votre région de bordeaux et nero soir
nous avons pu avoir une réunion en petit
groupe avec les amis de la première ce
qui ont vernis que tout cela soit
possible malgré les difficultés qui
existent et juste avant l'été et depuis
la campagne électorale tout cela ce
n'était pas simple et vont maintenant
prévoir la deuxième étape de ce travail
qui a été magnifique qui a surmonté
toutes les difficultés graves tant
d'amitié dead la deuxième étape et
commencent tous les étés après le 15
août lorsque beaucoup dès qu'une de pays
étrangers surtout ceux des pays
nordiques doivent nous quitter parce que
les rentrées scolaires sont plus rapide
que chez nous et à partir de ce moment
là il faut accuser tout les appels gelé
vue unir au soir ce matin qui ne cessent
d'arriver au secrétariat central de tous
les camps de personnes qui demandent
qu'on vienne prendre des clichés d'elle
et il va falloir arriver à voir
m
nouveaux volontaires parmi les français
qui en attend entre les absences de
vacances niveau des jeunes garçons et
filles pour vers le triage de tout coeur
abbas et pour achever les ramassages il
faut des adultes comme les femmes pour
aider à préparer et à réaliser les gangs
du bric à brac
c'est un travail considérable pour que
l'opération donne le maximum de
résultats qui possédait sur thur en même
temps il faut beaucoup de camions dans
chacune des villes il ya eu droit 34
villes qui ont eu de ces camps de
jeunesse dans votre région
dans chacune de ces localités woippy
joliment que dès samedi dès dimanche on
arrive à avoir des dizaines et des
dizaines de camions qui bénévolement
avec trop peur viennent s'offrir pour
achever serrana salle alors ça permettra
comme les années précédentes et c'est
sûr que cette année ça égalera au moins
ce qui a été près la dernière année
qu'elle était la plus étonnante qui a
permis de distribuer plus 80 nouvion de
lire qu'il souhaitait emmener italienne
mais quand cet effet dans l'italie du
nord par le travail des environs de 4000
jeunes venus des deux ne s'est plus 25
ou 30 nations divers droite lioret était
pétales né dans cette région et ses
équivalents
le pet même strate supérieure dès
maintenant comme dans les courses de
montagne le plus difficile c'est de
retour et la pince et ses parts de
noranda de se produire les bulles en
difficulté par la latitude
donc il ya la relève et que les la
jeunesse et tout le monde de la région
viennent donner son temps et cette aide
matérielle de camions à tous je viens
grand merci à furent duch de la première
heure qui ont permis de mettre en route
malgré des dépenses dans ce qui était
vraiment bien difficile merci à tous et
bon courage
lambert beauté
allez